Good morning, John.
I’m at the office. It's too early.
Hey, Nick and Nicole!
Nick: Hi.
Hank: Hi.
Nicole: Hi.
We’re doing something weird today.
We’re gonna show you in just a second.
Hank: Hello!
Denise: Hi, how are you?
Hank: Good! How are you doing?
Denise: Good.
Hank: This is Superintendent Juneau.
She is running for Congress.
Denise: Yup.
Hank: To represent the state of Montana.
You’re talking to my brother right now.
Denise: Oh, hi! How are you?
Hank: So we do all our shooting down here.
Oh yeah, that looks good.
Denise: Thank you!
Hank: Yeah
Nick: Go. Thank you.
Hank: Super official.
Hank: This is my audience.
Denise: Hi, audience!
Hank: And also my brother.
Denise: Hi, John.
Hank: I wanted to talk to you, and I’m so
grateful for you, for doing this, because
I don’t really want to talk about policy
or about your campaign or what you’re gonna
do for Montana when you’re in Washington,
which I imagine is most of what you talk about, which is good.
Denise: Right.
Hank: I just want to talk about, like, government,
being an elected official, which you are right now
Denise: Yup.
Hank: and, you know, how things have gotten
very partisan, and how that affects you running
for office, and you as a person also, ‘cause
I think oftentimes we forget that politicians are people.
But before we get into any of that, I’m
gonna give you a pop quiz.
Denise: All right.
Hank: I think you will know the answers to
all of these ones.
Denise: I hope so.
Hank: You are running for?
Denise: U.S. House of Representatives.
Hank: And that is?
Denise: A House of Congress.
Hank: So members of the House of Representatives
do what?
Denise: They make laws.
Hank: And the final question of the pop quiz
is how do you expect to afford the rents in D.C. if you win?
Denise: That’s gonna be a tough one.
Probably get roommates and have to figure
out who my friends in Congress are going to be.
Hank: You got all the questions right.
This is a goat.
Denise: Oh, awesome! Thank you so much.
Hank: Everyone gets a goat!
Nick: Everyone gets a goat.
Hank: You guys don’t get goats, I’m sorry. I was lying.
Denise: On MSU campus, they actually,
they've been doing a lot of work registering voters, and they have a vote goat.
Hank: Oh, okay.
Is it a live goat?
Denise: It is a live goat.
Hank: Like, if you vote, you get to like pet
the goat?
Denise: I don’t know!
It’s just a vote goat that goes around with
them to draw people over so then you can register them to vote.
Hank: Now, we are on to everyone’s favorite
topic, which is their own self, so we’re
gonna talk about you.
So you currently hold an elected office.
You are the Superintendent of Public Instruction.
Denise: Correct.
Hank: Which is just like the head of—
Denise: The head, yeah, it’s the head of
all the schools in Montana, basically.
Every four years, people vote for this position,
and it’s one of our statewide offices per
our state constitution.
Hank: Was your campaign for the statewide
office, was that significantly different than
what you’re experiencing now
Denise: Yes
Hank: running for a more high-profile thing?
Denise: Yes, totally.
You know, the issues are bigger, there’s
more scrutiny, you know, there’s all, there’s
a larger microscope on you.
You also get a bigger megaphone, and so that’s
good, too.
Hank: I imagine there’s also tough parts
of that, like not a lot of time scheduled for sleep.
Also, there’s a lot of people who are gonna
be saying nasty things about you.
Denise: Sure.
Hank: I’m just curious what the worst part
is, I guess.
Denise: It is that.
I think it’s the negativity in politics
right now.
It’s the divisiveness.
Good ideas sometimes don’t get to be discussed
because we draw ideological lines and then
talk about, you know, fear-based sorts of
issues rather than actually talking about
issues that matter.
Hank: So is it safe to say that during this
campaign, you kind of came out?
Denise. Mhm. So I introduced my partner.
You have somebody in your life and they, they
need to be there to support you.
Hank: Did you feel like that was something
that you needed to do for political reasons
as well as personal ones?
Denise: I, yeah, I think it was a mixture
of both.
People expect access.
They want to know who their candidates are,
and I think stepping up to this level from
Superintendent to Congress, it was important
to make sure things were out there because
of the negativity that can sometimes happen.
And it really hasn’t become an issue, which
is
Hank: Yeah, that’s great
Denise: great!
I think, particularly when we looked at Montana
and, you know, the stereotypes around our
state and its people, it actually hasn’t
become a political issue.
Hank: Yeah.
Denise: Which I think speaks volumes for our
state and our country and the direction we’re moving.
Hank: I was on your Twitter yesterday
Denise: Right
Hank: and it says in your bio, “54th generation
Montanan,” which made me laugh.
I just wanna know, how did you come to that
particular number?
Denise: I just figure it’s a long time,
and, you know, you can try to disprove it.
But I started like, American Indian people
have been in here before America was a country,
and it’s important to bring that aspect
of history to this race as well.
Hank: If you aren’t that tuned in, mostly
what you hear about government is the most dysfunctional things.
Denise: Right.
Hank: In America, we have very strong local
government, and I’m worried about the future
in which young people aren’t as interested
in that
Denise: Yup.
Hank: Because they see government as dysfunctional,
or because they just see it as like an unpleasant
task
Denise: Right
Hank: to try and get into that.
Denise: For every message you get and every
letter you get that says “I hate you”
and “You’re doing the wrong thing” and
“You’re horrible,” you get three or
four that are really good.
Or you run into people where, who say, “My
kid would not have graduated were it not for
Graduation Matters Montana.”
And yep, you’re gonna always get the haters,
but, you know, the good stuff always outweighs those.
Hank: I believe you, I guess.
Denise: Yeah.
You should!
Hank: What do you think politicians can do
to make it feel, like, to put the government,
like the running of our country ahead of winning
the election?
Denise: Be present.
90% of politics is showing up.
And you show up where people are gathered
and you listen, and, you know, you put aside
your partisan hat and you actually listen
to people about, what are your issues?
Why are they challenging?
And how can we make it better?
I mean that’s really what the function
of government is, to make things better, and
that’s why elections matter.
It really does matter who sits in those seats,
that can actually get down and do the business
of their government.
Hank: How terrifying is a debate?
Denise: Oh, it’s scary!
Hank: It seems so scary!
Denise: It is!
I mean, it is something where, I mean, you
kind of have to guess on what you’re going to get asked.
There’s always a curveball, you never know.
Getting up on that stage, it’s something.
I mean you
Hank: I can’t imagine
Denise: are definitely awake.
Last debate actually had an audience question:
If you’re elected, how will you help LGBTQ
people in the country?
That sort of was a new question we hadn’t
been asked in previous debates, and so my
answer was, number one, get elected.
Hank: That’s not fair!
Denise: It’s very fair.
Hank: So, I guess my last question is just
how do you, how do you help Americans believe in government?
Denise: Well I think, number one, get elected.
I mean, I’m not naive about, you know, there’s
a lot that needs to be fixed in government,
and we need to really start moving away from
such divisive politics, but through my life
and through my role as an elected official,
I know that things can happen, and so I do,
I’m optimistic, and I think most people
who run for office, they want to make sure
that things get better for the people that
they represent.
You’re stepping up, putting yourself on
the line, you’re opening yourself up for
scrutiny, but you’re also opening yourself
up to have real conversations with people.
And when you’re elected, to make a difference,
to make a positive difference for the people
who elected you. and I think that’s really
powerful.
Hank: Well, thank you very much.
Denise: Yeah, thanks.
Hank: This was fun.
John, I’ll see you on Tuesday.
That’s how I end my videos.
John, there are so many serious arguments
that need to be had, so many issues that need
to be discussed, that it can sometimes feel
hard to justify just having a conversation
with a person who is being voted on to be
in a public office as if they are a person.
But I think that it’s really important to
try and do.
To imagine these people as people, especially
at this moment when the information silos
and the voter dicommunication strategies are
combining to create the most extreme partisanship
I've ever seen in my lifetime.
The result of all of this is that no one ever
talks about the things that work, and so everybody
thinks that everything’s broken, but it’s
not.
Yes, things need to be maintained, and we
all need to work to do that maintainence,
but that doesn’t mean that it’s never
been worse and that we’re losing and that
everything is crashing down around us.
Americans, humans, we have problems right
now, but we are good at taking on problems.
I obviously cut a lot out of this interview.
The full interview is like a half an hour
long.
I would love it if you would go watch the
whole thing.
We got deeper into several of the topics from
this video, and then talked about stuff that
isn’t in this video at all.
I thought it was a fascinating conversation,
and I hope that you will as well.
You can watch that video here.
Click there. There's a link in the description.
And of course, as a final reminder, educational
videos are exempt from the time limit, so
stop talking about punishments in the comments.